Honorable j congressman says that she cannot be a hypocrite and that
is why he calls Piedad Córdoba a white bandit on the day of his death,
Hippocrita says the one who was elected under progressive
flags that he abandoned the first moment he became governor,
which in reality he never had the intention of defending from the legislature.
You JP represent so little the Greens that today the
women of that party are calling for your expulsion.
They sent a letter to the National Directorate of the
collectivity in which they ask that it be sanctioned with the
utmost rigor and isolated from the collectivity
in order to install a President.
With the exception of Catherine Hubinow and Angelica Lozano,
who refused to sign the letter and give statements about JP.
Um Why is it?
In the letter they assure that JP reproduces a hate speech based on
defamation and falsehood and that they are a political force that does
not agree with the actions of negative populism is that I share the
opinion of the gender commission of the green in requesting the
expulsion of this gentleman from a party that has historically
defended progressive causes,
JP spreads violent speeches and
disinformation You say you can not be a hypocrite,
but you and your way of doing politics are the word hypocrisy at its best.